Goldman senior scholar at the Davis
center for Russian studies at Harvard
University recounts Russia's economic
collapse in 1998 and it's really a
decade later as a financial force due to
its energy wealth the program hosted by
the southern Center for International
Studies in Atlanta is 90 minutes of
course it is a great honor for all of us
to have Marshall Goldman be a guest here
at the southern Centre for International
Studies a guest in Atlanta and
representing several wonderful
institutions with which many of us have
had relationships in the past over over
a wide wide range of subjects and
interests and courses and and whole
degrees and that but that is marshal as
you knows for economists as the
professor at Wellesley College but he's
also a senior scholar and for many years
the associate director of the data
center at Harvard University a center
that was really preeminent in studying
over decades of the developments in what
was the Soviet Union and now the Russian
Federation so with that Marshall I'm
very very glad to for you to be here I
would set this up we are here to talk
about Petro State the book Petro State
the idea Petro State the practical and
political entity that is moving forward
it's moving forward of course
miraculously from its from its past it's
especially most recent past if any of us
I think or except for maybe mr. Putin
himself had thought what would happen
after 1998 when the country was
essentially bankrupt and and under great
challenge of people would have very much
doubted that we would have this
conversation here tonight or the few
that did see it coming or the
possibilities are actually very very few
as far as I know but I think being a
historian I have to at least say that I
loved
name it because part of our what we're
intrigued about here is the petrol state
and we know that it is a coin phrase of
course coming from petroleum but I think
I have to suggest that since the first
four letters are actually the the
Russian spelling of peter the great's
name that that Johto state has some
perhaps meaning given to origins of some
of the ideas especially as it relates to
the interaction with the West with high
technology with great developmental
issues that Peter the Great actually
introduced in the country or at least
facilitated in many profound ways it
also is the first letters of the name of
the city that figures prominently and in
in this book and in the past of many of
the prominent players that are major
actors and players and leaders in the
Petro State as Marshall has so
wonderfully described it one of the
reviewers has said this is the book that
is describing what has happened over
this last decade or really since the the
re-emergence of Russia as this very
significant energy powerhouse and how
that turns into political power and
political action is the subject of the
book and then potential conversation and
and of course what we will all see as
things develop but with that I certainly
welcome Marshall Goldman here and it's a
privilege to be on the same sort of
stage with you thanks thanks very much
wait I I don't think you knew it but you
set me up when we were picking the title
for the book my agents had called it
Petro State a first time I've ever had
an agent my wife said no people think
that means prostate but it's so so that
was not what Peter had in mind and I
mean it's just say that it's it's a
pleasure to be here because as this is
the most exciting thing I've ever
engaged in and when I got this agent
this agent said
but you can't do this like your other
books because you know then you assign
them as a textbook and took you told the
students that would be an exam and so
they had to read it today you're not
teaching anymore you can't give exams so
you've got to make it so people want to
read it but I said if I do that I'll
lose my license as an economist so so
and I said what what in the world can I
write about that would make it exciting
and but then a year ago we went off I
was invited to go to Russia there's this
meeting called the bald eye hills group
and they take us out in the end the
climax as I was meeting with with Putin
and this time the third year that we
were doing it we know that for years now
the third year there were we were going
to go out with the theme was oil and so
they took us out to Siberia to the to
the pre-op sky you feel I said well
maybe I'll find something there and I
got there and it was very interesting
but I you know I write about it it would
have been forced but then they took us
to Gaza from headquarters and those of
you who've been to Moscow know that
Gazprom headquarters are really this
tall building striking in the southwest
region of Moscow and so I'm going to do
something that I hate it when other
people do but I'm going to do it anyway
it sorta read from my own book which
describes going into this to this
building you know when I start reading
people why did you have to read it he
hasn't read it before but but you may
get a flavor and I'm this really kind of
sets off this whole change in atmosphere
and I think this describes it as as much
as anything can but at first I was
puzzled where were they taking us for
such a big sleek glass Moscow high-rise
Gospels elevated its headquarters
building was tiny five people could
barely squeeze in in its hall corridors
were narrow very narrow this was after
all the world's largest producer of
natural gas not to mention Russia's
largest company following a short walk
we were ushered into his dark and silent
room where nothing seemed to be
happening strange it was only when all
the members of our group had made their
way up on those elevators that the room
suddenly came alive then for a time I
felt as if I'd wandered into a NASA
Space Center
or was it a James Bond movie said all
that was missing was that out of body
voice and toning welcome mr. Goldman we
were expecting you if you've seen the
John James Bond okay anyway in front of
me covering the whole hundred foot wall
in the room was a map with the spider
web-like maze of natural gas pipelines
reaching from East Siberia west of the
Atlantic and from the Arctic Ocean south
to the Caspian and Black Seas
manipulating this display where gospel
dispatchers three men controlling the
flow of gas Proms gas to East and West
European consumers of this Russian
natural gas monopoly no wonder there was
tight security there was also a sense of
self assurance as measured by the value
of its corporate stock by the summer of
2006 when we were there gospel and I
know some of you have invested in it
this day dominated joint stock
corporation until 1992 it was actually
the Soviet Ministry of the gas industry
had become the world's third largest
corporation only private shareholders
own Exxon Mobil and General Electric
were larger if you've been following it
today you know that actually it's number
tuna because General Electric stock has
fallen and so it's the largest
corporation but in terms of capitalized
value as Exxon Mobil in Gotham is now
number two and then one more sentence
that I'm through with a flick of a
switch those dispatchers sitting in this
Moscow room could freeze and indeed have
frozen entire countries at the very
least they could send their citizens off
in a panic in search of sweaters scarves
and blankets well for me that that sets
the theme of of this fascinating story
less than 10 years ago August 17th 1998
Russia was effectively bankrupt and you
have tables in front of you and if you
look at them
the dark line give me this is where the
Economist come very well don't fall
asleep just yet but but if but if you
look at the at the the dark the dark
lines our GDP then you can see what was
happening from the early 90s of Naberius
begins in the late eighties the russian
economy goes into a freefall it drops
and
one year almost the 16% chilly enough by
the 1998 as a slight uptick in 1997 but
by 1998 the cumulative fall is about 40
percent that's worse than what we
suffered in the Great Depression so you
can under fee love how bad the Russians
the Russian economy is doing how
humiliated the Russians were because
from being a superpower country they had
fallen into not being significant at all
they were bankrupt effectively
bankrupted on August 17th 1998 the
Russian country as a country declared
that its bonds were worthless they would
not redeem their bonds the stock market
in Russia fell the currency the ruble
became worthless there was no money in
the Treasury there were echoes in this
country because some of you may remember
with pain long-term capital management a
Greenwich Connecticut hedge fund that
basically collapsed the Federal Reserve
Bank had to come in to prop them up our
own stock market in response fell 20
percent and we were worried that we
would go through a similar meltdown so
this is what was they were facing now
what is significant here is that in 1999
you see that the GDP begins to go up and
it continues to go up it's gone up every
year since then in August 1999 Yeltsin
who was the president and presiding over
this collapse a point of Lattimer
Boonton as the prime minister he becomes
Prime Minister in August 1999 December
31st he becomes the Acting President
because Putin Elson announces his
premature resignation and in March he's
elected now looks old from 1999 on now
the GDP begins to go up with with just
consistently and so for the Russians
it's easy to understand they associate
Putin with nothing else he comes into
office and the economy begins to respond
and Russia comes back and the Treasury
is filled now Russia has savings of
in a sovereign fund of approximately 500
billion dollars worth of gold rubles ho
not rubles but gold and dollars in Euros
the ruble has gained 20 percent value
relative to the dollar so they are
floating and so thinking to understand
why the Russian people say it's Putin
who get it and that though if you take a
public opinion poll 80% of the Russian
people say Putin is the one we support
and we want to sustain so the question
is to what extent and this is what the
book looks at to what extent is this all
due to Putin and to what extent is it
independent and I'm old enough to know
now that when I give lectures people are
awake the first 10 minutes after a while
by the middle of the lecture they
thinking when's he going to end and so
they're not paying attention by the end
of lecture there everybody races for the
door so I'll tell the answer now some
people said what does he say and you
know what the answer is and the answer
is Putin did make a difference but not
because he didn't create this what what
is created and again to give you that
answer so you can think about other
things is you see there the line
adjacent to that dark line and that
shows the change in oil production and
this is most unusual in social science
whenever oil production drops GDP drops
and even in 1997 when it goes up a touch
GDP goes up and thereafter without fail
it's a perfect correlation so that it's
clear that oil production drives this
and so I tell my wife that look if I had
been a pointed Prime Minister of Russia
in August 1999 and oil prices begin to
go up as they do and oil production
begins to go up even I would look like a
genius so it's not unless you can tell
me that Putin is the reason oil
production drops and the oil prices drop
and the oil prices go up again you can't
really say that it's Putin's doing it's
really a case of oil and that's why I
call the book Petro state it's not Saudi
Arabia in fact Russians producing it has
been producing more petroleum than Saudi
Arabia
largest producer petroleum in the world
it's not the largest exporter Saudi
Arabia's and Saudi Arabia's now again
increasing production but that that is
the explanation so you can go home now
but you won't but you won't hear what
Putin did so let me now say what
difference did Putin make well that goes
to the next table if you look at it and
who did make a difference
he didn't affect oil price changes that
of course is the market and oil prices
go from $10 a barrel to today hundreds
140 dollars a barrel so if it and it's
that change in oil price which has led
oil companies in Russia to go out into
the extreme conditions particularly in
the Arctic and begin to invest otherwise
they wouldn't do it if the conditions
are too extreme so what did Putin do
well you know Putin was chained as a
lawyer and then he joined the KGB and
then he went to East Germany where he
served as a KGB agent but the Berlin
Wall came down in 1989 and there was no
yet he was unemployed so he went back to
Leningrad as it was then called and he
got a job with his former one of his
former law professors a man by name of
sub Chuck who became the governor of st.
Petersburg and he put Putin in charge of
foreign economic relations that's what
Katie it Wayne knows this is what the
KGB agent is is always you're dealing
with is always a KGB agent but then
subshock lost the election and what to
do again
Putin was unemployed so what happened is
well he was in this kind of limbo in
1997 he decided to write a short
dissertation we we have it and what he
what he does is he examines a question
what should Russia be doing to bring
back its superpower status what can we
do what do we have we don't have
manufacturing our military is
discredited with bogged down in Chechnya
we don't have anything the only thing we
have going for us are our raw materials
and so he says we've got to take those
raw materials many of which had been
turned over to private companies take
them back put them in control and use
them to promote Russia's interests
and so he dodged this notion of what he
calls national champions and the thesis
has been available it's been translated
and he calls for the creation of
national champions what we should do is
go back and take over that gasps take
over that oil the ferrous metals are
non-ferrous metals put them in entities
which are controlled by the state and
use them to advance Russia's interests
just like ExxonMobil advances the United
States interest now as a sidelight here
if this were fiction you'd say it no it
couldn't be real but but it is real it
turns out that we know that Putin
plagiarized that that idea from two
professors from Pittsburgh University he
took as a hold 10 to 15 pages
word-for-word in Russian of course but
that book their book had been translated
into Russian next time you see Putin you
can ask him worded it that it comes to
come from but it's it's we just got to
see yeah we saw him in somebody that got
actually the guy who discovered us was
made by the Clifford Gotti even he
didn't ask footin this kind of thing but
it but it's there and look at this table
and see what happened when he wrote this
it was just what you would write off as
an academic exercise which means it'll
never come to fruition because this in
1997 Putin is now you know in
saint-petersburg
no it's just an ordinary administrator
there's no chance he's got to go to
Moscow if he does go to Moscow how in
the world is he going to be Prime
Minister much less the president but he
does he gets there and look what happens
he's elected president on his own in
March 2000 immediately he begins to
implement this notion and what has been
happening is he is concerned by the fact
that the people who had privatized these
companies including gospel have been
stripping assets taking the assets off
from what were these companies not
wholly owned by them and transferred
them to other companies that they
controlled now Cherno Bearden who's
first on this list actually had been the
minister of the gas industry in the
Soviet era he then becomes Prime
Minister and he
and his his deputy if you go down fourth
on the list a man by name of Yakov takes
over and they become he becomes the head
of the CEO of Goss room they privatized
the gas ministry as I mentioned in the
beginning and they take over and they
begin to strip off assets one of the
companies they strip off assets to is a
company called echar now the strangest
thing is that it or is located
you've never guess in Jacksonville
Florida
Lyon Jacksonville phone and why not it's
warmer it's nice and wonderful Beach yes
green and so interim becomes the second
large producer of natural gas in Russia
and if your natural if your if your
energy company in the United States
what's the first thing you do you get a
lobbyist so you know it's like any
red-blooded energy company that have a
lobbyist in Washington so they find a
young woman they pay her a half million
dollars and only by coincidence does it
turn out that her father is a
congressman not from Jacksonville
Florida from Philadelphia it's not too
close but you take them where you can
get them his name is Kurt Weldon and
Kurt Weldon becomes in effect the man
from Achara related to gospel and as far
as we can tell the ownership of etre is
is very opaque but it consists of the
children eternal minute in vyasa room
their wives and as well as other senior
executives and their mistresses they're
all there together it's a nice it's a
nice happy family and etre then now is
here and what do they do
Weldon is the man from it or he hosts
them he has a reception for the
executives from interet the Library of
Congress he goes to Jacksonville to help
them dedicate their new offices he
arranges for an eight hundred thousand
dollar grant from the Development Office
the US Trade and Development Office to
help interative elip natural gas
deposits in Russia which is not normally
what US organizations funded by the
government are supposed to do
then you know as a subplot at a subplot
how do we know all this well you may
remember the Department of Justice our
use Department of Justice was accused of
digging into dirt on various congressmen
in order to increase the number of
Republicans to defeat the Democrats and
indeed Weldon loses the election in 2006
after the Department of Justice reveals
all this information only trouble is
Weldon as a Republican somebody got
their signals mixed they were supposed
to go out after Democrats you know so
you could see why this is all so
fascinating and so now he's out and
indeed it's Reneau longer has it's it's
congressman but what what Putin is doing
now is getting rid of these people
because they'd stolen assets from
Russian so he gets rid of charitable
Meriden he gets rid of the ah Karev and
then he goes out after the oil people
here as well bringing the back they've
been privatized he goes after Berezovsky
taking back Sid naps that's transferred
to a company called Rosneft and the one
that we've heard most recently about at
the bottom is Michael Carter coughs key
he was the head of Yukos he was Russia's
richest man he's now in prison in
Siberia serving eight years a meal
problem unless the new president does
something to change that he'll be there
till he dies probably so anyway this is
what's taking place and I'm the next
table again in the book who do you bring
in when you get rid of these other guys
who do you bring in and so he brings in
what the Russians have come to call
sulla Viki silho means strength and you
can translate this like these are the
law & order types in this country would
be as if the senior executives of the
FBI go in and are going to business
after they retire or the Pentagon
generals go into business the only thing
in Russia they're doing it
simultaneously if you look at this list
that takes section for example and and I
actually asked Putin this question the
last time we met how can you have a
situation where such a is the deputy
administrator of the Kremlin which is a
very senior position and that's his day
job actually he was then promoted to
First Deputy Prime Minister after that
but then on top of that he's also the
chairman of the board of Rosneft Rosneft
is now Russia's largest company at
state-owned for the most part there are
private shares in it but it's
state-owned so here's a man who has two
jobs both are full-time how could he do
them well besides which how can you
expect such an to be impartial if an
issue of what should we do with energy
companies comes up before the Kremlin it
can't be you can't rule against his own
company and besides which you're going
to create a new group of oligarchs
you're getting rid of the old oligarchs
you get rid of Berezovsky you've got rid
of you've got rid of garlic offski but
you're bringing in new people and more
than that if you look down at the bottom
they're doing something that never
happened in the Soviet era they're
creating the children of the executives
are being put in these cushy jobs in the
Soviet era they may have gone into
think-tanks academic institutions but
not making money so look at the bottom
that's probably the biggest
embarrassment upon tree chef who was the
head of the KGB his two sons one goes to
work for Venice toward Bank which is
State Bank and the other is for Rosneft
the company we've just been talking
about so you can see there's going to be
all kinds of conflict of interest all
kinds of new wealth being created or
being transferred to these executives so
today in fact according to Forbes
magazine Russia has the second largest
number of billionaire second only to the
United States we still do some things
right we still have more billionaires
than anybody else but they just eclipse
Germany to become number two New York
actually used to have the largest number
of billionaires now now Moscow has more
than New York which again is a
reflection of this change of this new
wealth that's being created so these
people are clearly very loyal to Putin
they've also enriched themselves along
the way and in the process of course
Russia has benefited enormous Lee now
I'll just end this with with a look at
the last table I thought I doing work
just my research I said I really should
get some idea of what how important
Russia is for the supply of oil and gas
to Europe so I went to the library I
went to the tower library and I gathered
the information from the international
energy authorities or the agencies of
handbook so I went back to my office and
I put this table together and I said you
know this this is really startling and
the rest of the world should be aware of
it and so I decided I would write the
book just gives you some feel for it
look at Germany Germany gets 42 percent
of its natural gas now from Russia and
this and that's just enormous least
important the oil if oil is cut off it
will be inconvenient you'll have to go
elsewhere but you have to pay more to
get it but if there F is the way that
for example should cut us off well we
can other places we can go in good we
are indeed already importing petroleum
from Russia about 10 billion dollars
worth it'll take a while it'll be more
expensive but we can find another tanker
we can find another a pipeline we can
find another railroad car another tank
truck but with natural gas that's really
like an umbilical cord because that
Titan doll comes out of the pipeline the
pipeline cost 3 to 6 billion dollars you
can't have a standby pipeline just in
case they cut it off so you put all your
money in that pipeline you can't have
capital just sitting there idle for
three six billion dollars and sooner or
later there may be liquefied natural gas
but even that requires at least a
billion dollars expenditure to process
the gas to transport it with special
tankers and then to reprocess it again
so if you've got that pipeline up you've
got them politically in a stranglehold
and it in my mind it has already begun
to influence what is what Germany is is
doing because the Germans have to
calculate it's not worry it's not worth
it to rile the Russians over smaller
issues in fear that they will cut us off
for one reason or another and if you
look at this list you can see that even
Italy is very heavily dependent on
Russia even though it's at the end of
the pipeline it's more you know in the
west of the south I mean the East End
the south you know the west and the
south so but they are going to be
affected
in France if you go to Eastern Europe
Central Europe you see they get a
hundred percent of the natural gas and
that's going back to that first page
that I read you can see why that sets
the theme for everything that follows
it's really critical that it has a
political hold I say we too are in a
position now in the United States where
we are also becoming more and more
dependent on Russia for for me it has
it's good at this point because it's
petroleum we are importing on the order
now of about 700 million dollars worth
of petroleum a year ten of it is coming
from Russia what that helps to diversify
so the more sources of supply they are
that's fine it means the Russians build
up money because they've got this
favorable trade balance so they now
that's why they went from bankruptcy ten
years ago to a Treasury now that holds
over five hundred billion dollars worth
of assets almost 600 yeah and that makes
them the third in the world after China
and Japan but again we're in less than a
decade from bankruptcy to affluence
that's filtering down to the public so
there is new prosperity but it's the gas
which doesn't bring him that much money
but does give them that political clout
and that's what it seems to be as
important for the rest of the world to
understand and this gives them a new a
new hubris a new arrogance as it were
and I will just end this rant by showing
you we try to reflect how Russia is back
and how you know they now feel they're
their power and their strength in a
variety of ways
last February about 2007 at a press
conference Putin was asked about George
Bush the two of them have a very unusual
relationship in the four times I've met
with Putin each time he brings up George
Bush dodge george w bush and it was
complementary way unsolicited comments
you know the last time around for
example putin said he really appreciated
George Bush because George Bush went off
to the G
a meeting that took place in st.
Petersburg there was a lot of criticism
of that there was pressure for him not
to go within the United States without
the United States Putin came I mean food
said Bush came and he appreciated that
I've met with George Bush once and he
too has positive things to say about
Putin although a little more critical
but you know the two of them their body
language is absolutely phenomenal so
they really get along with each other
anyway so Putin is asked at this press
conference how do you get along with
George Bush and so he says I can do
business with George Bush and I said to
myself gee I've heard something like
that before where had I heard that well
this is what remember Margaret Thatcher
said about Mikhail Gorbachev before
Gorbachev became the general secretary
what with a very patronizing way what
she was saying yes I could do business
with that peasant from Stavropol now
it's turned around and what is Putin
saying yes I can do business with that
cowboy from Crawford I mean it's just
again in a patronizing and here are
absolutely ad with another press
conference this was in June just a year
ago and Putin is asked by the president
by correspondent from der Spiegel says
mr. president former federal Chancellor
Gerhard schröder
called you a pure Democrat do you
consider yourself as such just as a
interject here as you can see many
things about food but a pure Democrat
just just no way anyway Putin's answers
and I read the transcript he laughs and
I appear Democrat of course I am
absolutely but you know what the problem
is it's not even a problem it's a real
tragedy the problem is that I'm all
alone the only one of my kind in the
whole wide world just look what's
happening in North America again let me
interject he's going to turn the world
on its head look what's happening in
North America all true but listen it's
simply awful
Torche your homeless people Guantanamo
people detained without trial and
investigation just look at what's
happening in Europe harsh treatment of
demonstrators rubber bullets and tear
gas use first and one capital then into
another demonstrators killed in the
streets all true but
forgotten thanks man look in the mirror
you know all of these things are exactly
what has happened in Russia many ends
and this is the climax there's no one to
talk to since Mahatma Gandhi died well
thank you Marshall alright well well
maybe maybe some of those comments do
indicate why the man has the power that
he has today if he's able to say such
things and in his case always with a
straight face one of the things that
intrigues me about both about the book
and about the reality too is the
centrality of the gospel this large
company that now just in the last week
Alexey Miller who is the new CEO claims
that shortly it will become a trillion
dollar company it would be the largest
corporation in the world not only
through their distribution of gas in the
sail around the world but by very
significant investments and downstream
things this is right so much so that
some you know funny folks have called
the country instead of Russia we should
call it God's promised on and a run by
Boonton so but the jokes aside gospel is
central to this thing and yet I think
I'm correct that we haven't mentioned
yet the former chairman of Goss prohm
who is now president of the country how
is this bridge if all of you layout is
right and it sits right there in the
book and in the breath I think it's
pretty obvious what gospel has done but
how is that bridge going to happen and
how is Putin going to either continue
maintain control or what will this new
relationship be because it's not the
same as it was people I'm glad I should
have mentioned that and you're
absolutely right to ask me about it if
you go back to this table with the
Salovey key again if you look down you
will find the objectives name he was one
of these two people serving dual jobs he
was determined of the Kremlin
administration then he became
and one of the first deputy Prime
Minister's simultaneously holding on to
the job as chairman of the board of gas
chromo and it's actually he only left
that position just two or three days ago
so he was doing both there's no doubt
you know this is why the National
Champion it Goss problem is serving this
Putin himself in one of our meetings
said that he envisions the day when
gospel will be a trillion dollar
corporation just as you you mentioned it
you know they see their well being as a
country economically as well as
politically being that in turn were
intermingled with with Gazprom so the
idea of now is the president and how can
he forget his path he too is going to be
on a list of oligarchs in a very short
period of time
indeed I say it you know this is why
Russia now has more than anybody else
but the United States in terms of
billionaires but clearly Medvedev will
have those interests and it there's no
know you know hiding the fact that it
kind of carries the flag and it carries
the flag in terms of wealth I mean I've
spoken to some of the people in this
room before the session started and you
know Americans have invested in gospel -
it's been a very profitable investment
the in year 2000 its capitalized value
was about six to eight billion dollars
today it's about four hundred billion
you know i say say the second-largest in
russian on the way if Putin has his way
as Prime Minister and certainly the
venom has his way to a trillion dollars
there are people here are in this room
also who are engaged in one way or
another in business or business
activities are interested in in business
that is being conducted in Russia one of
the questions is what are they going to
do with all this money the wealth
creation is very apparent you just do
the math the question is what are they
going to use this for we just for
political purposes we I think you
pointed out in the book that even at a
7% growth in GDP they're not done
be able to re-establish themselves as a
military power pooting believes that too
in their their principal economist and
Russia also all say that so what are
they going to do with this massive
amount of money do they have the
capability first of all to handle it and
then what will they use it for great
question
they're using it in part they said
initially Putin brought some of the
economic advisors he was working with in
Saint Petersburg to Moscow and these
were more or less professional
economists they said look we've got to
isolate this money it'll kill us
otherwise because we'll have inflation
it'll flood the country so they put it
in a Stabilization Fund for law but now
they're getting antsy and political
pressure is where we should be spending
some of it our highways are in bad shape
our infrastructures in bad shape we
should be giving more support to them
elderly but in addition to that
particularly the money that goes to the
corporations because you know the oil
money in Italy is going to the
corporation's first of all it is being
used to buy up other companies and right
here in River City
so for example lukoil
which is now one of their second or
third largest oil companies it's
privately held has bought up what used
to be getting oils of those of you who
are used to traveling along the east
coast there are North East Coast New
Jersey New York you will find we're
getting oil stations were they are now
lukoil now I also have to say that
ConocoPhillips owns 20% of lukoil so
they own 20% of Lugar and lukoil owns
all of getting and they're all together
going into Iraq where lukoil was was
operating before but so is to buy
companies and then if you look at the
steel industry it's even more dramatic
in the steel industry sever style which
is a Russian company has brought up a
whole network of American steel
companies from my point of view again
it's terrific because Americans aren't
investing in steel industry let somebody
do it and the Russians are coming and
actually bringing some of their
technology which is ironic because in
our
earlier days we used to watch American
companies take our technology to Russia
now the Russians are bringing the
technology back they brought up Oregon
steel another Russian steel companies
brought up Oregon steel in Oregon the
River Rouge plant in Detroit sparrows
you know this there's in Baltimore so
there is a real estate in Mississippi
and Jack that's right they've just
bought something in Jackson and also
wheeling steel so there's just a whole
network of things r1 platinum producer
in Montana they've bought these up and
they're doing the same thing of course
in Europe they're you know the Russians
are coming
literally this way which is quite a
dramatic thing and what is also
interesting is that we're in Europe
there's some nervousness particularly as
they get to buy up gas companies and
distribution companies so far there's
not been much of a fuss in the United
States because we welcome that
investment if somebody wants to invest
in our steel industry come on please do
it so so that's been helpful but it
politically it could be a problem down
the road
but if you use all that capital for
investment then what are you doing
internally with because of the
infrastructure you're talking about an
even reinvestment in the infrastructure
of the oil and gas industry itself is is
of great concern or could be if there's
a bunch of money how they're going to
invest that and also shore up their own
domestic situation and produce things we
talk about the Dutch disease of the when
you when you have these natural
resources you stop doing manufacturing
you stop doing things internal the con
what do they go all prosperity has come
at a price and the prices you say is the
Dutch disease one of the things that has
happened what is the Dutch disease the
Dutch disease you bring in all this
money that comes in from your export of
energy oil or gas that pushes up the
value of the ruble and I think I said
the ruble has increased 20 percent
relative to the dollar which means the
ruble is very expensive and if things
are priced in rubles that makes them
very expensive to buy so what happens
you don't buy them so you their export
of manufacturing goods is
never been good it's not good now but it
also means that for the Russian
consumers the ruble is strong they can
buy a lot they can buy a lot of goods
from the United States because it were
cheap now where our goods are very cheap
because a dollar is weak and so you
while your economy is growing with all
this money coming in you're killing your
manufacturing sector and that's what the
Dutch disease wasn't they they worry
about that but at the same time and if
you please don't ask me because I can't
I puzzled about it and I can't find the
answer you see the money coming down on
the street it's at least in the cities
how it gets there because the not
manufacturing is a bit of a mystery
services yes are very very prosperous or
a lot of service activities and you can
do it that way but manufacturing is bad
some of the manufacturing where it is
good is protected by tariffs that the
Russians have put up so there are now
almost every automobile manufacturer now
is assembling automobiles in st.
Petersburg American German Japanese
other Europeans because all this
disposable income has just been flooding
in the country it's growing at ten
fifteen percent a year but if they if
Russia ever joins the World Trade
Organization that means they'll have to
lower the tariffs and that that industry
will be will be destroyed so it's a bit
of a problem but I do have to say one
thing I want to say something positive
about Putin because on the whole that's
had much of anything about any old bike
rack well you never know you know what I
mean he deserves credit for this
legitimately one of our meetings
somebody asked him what's your greatest
accomplishment you know the after four
meetings the questions get rather soft
and he said one of the things I'm
proudest of is that when I came into
office in 2000 again the bad country had
hidden bankruptcy he said over a third
of the population 33 percent of the
public was below the poverty line today
it's 14 to 15 percent so somehow or
other some of that money is filtering
down and it's not because they change
the definition of the poverty line you
can really you can really see automobile
traffic jams in Russia construction
shops that are that are filled with
goods again in our gay the shelves were
empty literally empty and now they've
got not only you know they import them
but you know consumer goods and luxury
goods there because this says maybe some
more about Boston and it says about
Moscow but there are luxury shops and in
Moscow's that Boston doesn't compare it
all well you know people say Boston is
rather shabby to begin with but but it
but you know here you really see where
the mystery its artistic but but here
you know you think they were selling
more Mercedes automobiles in Moscow than
in the other car and more than any other
capital city except for Germany itself
so that's a reflection that we do have
that well I think it is time we need to
open this up we've got quite some time
that we want to take for people to ask
questions remember please raise your
hand and get the mic I'll start on the
front row that's a good place to start
with John Wood great time professor
Goldman I want to go back and in a way
play devil's advocate in terms of those
that are in the energy industry will
first and foremost point out that 80% of
what has been extracted is from West
Siberia and 93% eight percent in natural
gas 93 percent in oil and that
essentially within the next three to
four years there will be somewhere
between a 15 to 20 percent drop in the
production from there and therefore
there is an issue of whether it's peaked
articles even in the AIA about the
questioning the estimations by Gazprom
and so it raises the issue of are they
going to be there is it's just an Indian
summer the other side is obviously they
need our help and then it comes into
this whole area of the macroeconomic
environment of resource nationalism
which has a regressive tax system the
mineral extraction tax for example and
then obviously the recent foreign
strategic law which seemed to suggest on
the one
and a desire and President Putin when he
was president and and Megadeth have said
come in but on the other hand you've got
this very regressive tax regime yes
there have been some reductions in order
to incentivize the issue of oil so
you've got this issue of is this real
anyway and many people in the oil and
gas industry pointing to the fact well
you know the fact is they've not got to
East Siberia yet the seismic issues and
exploration issues are enormous the
other side is the enormous investment it
would be required they're going to need
even if they've got about a trillion
dollars they're going to need two to
three trillion dollars to develop the
North stream South Stream ESPO shot
command East Siberia Sakhalin and so
you've got on the one hand an enormous
need for money and we have obviously
have enormous needed dependency but on
the other hand a number of impediments
at a macroeconomic level that constrain
us from going forward what do you think
first of all the Peak Oil argument
that's gone forward do you think they'll
get to East Siberia and the Far East
before the plunger drops and on the
other hand the whole tax and legal
framework you know when you have issues
like shell being thrown into Sakhalin
the tea nbk of akka vodka it's not sort
of even though you want to be there do
you want to be there
yeah I feel like I just had my general
examination from my PhD
great questions I'm glad I'm dealing
with a group that doesn't know anything
about energy that is also very well it
you know this is something they were but
first let me go back a little bit and I
talked about it in the book actually
just just these really should have got
these questions first of all in back in
the 1970s the CIA our CIA came out with
a report saying that Russia which was
then the world's largest producer
petroleum would suddenly become one of
the world's largest importers of
petroleum by the mid 1980s because they
were using drilling methods that were
destructive and they were ruining the
thing I came up to my first book on
energy was that
saying that the CIA was wrong which is
was a pretty gutsy thing to do at the
time because it just seemed to me
illogical well it turned out that so far
I've been right although if you look at
this this table you saw in the early
early 90s when production is going down
maybe their day had come
but what happened while prices went up
then when oil prices went up then they
decided ok was worth doing that
investment and so then they hit this new
peak where again Russia becomes the
largest producer of petroleum even Saudi
Arabia cuts back a little bit so larger
than Saudi Arabia this year this quarter
first quarter of this year it's going
down again and that hits right to the
point that that you made one of the
Deputy CEOs of Lukoil said made a public
speech in which he said oil production
is going down and you'd better be aware
of the country better be aware of it and
the government better be aware of it
because if this continues we have may
have hit it and it's going down again
well of course for me just brought back
memories right away of the CIA and of
course he said you know why is it going
down it's going down for the reasons
that you mentioned when oil prices reach
27 dollars a barrel and 80% tax gets
kicks in which is couture II and so this
executive from lukoil said you want us
to go out into East Siberia there's no
infrastructure there at those prices
with that retained earnings after taxes
it doesn't pay Putin got the message and
Putin says ok if you want to go out into
new areas where there's no
infrastructure you're immune from
there's a tax holiday your immune from
that so it's still going to be out there
the investment in indeed is enormous as
you say I just was in Moscow about two
or three weeks ago
Consulting whatever you want to call it
with style style oil is a Norwegian
company that after having been told it
would not have an opportunity to develop
Stockman was invited back in and so now
they're examining this question what
should we do how should we proceed
because if we put in money are we going
to end up discovering that we're going
to be abused by the Russians as shale
oil has as ExxonMobil has as BP has as
everybody has who's in there I'm not
sure they'll they'll be able to escape
that but but my point is this they bring
it they bring in star oil which is a
Norwegian company because they got
experienced dealing in the Arctic so
they're now developing the stockmen
which is in the Arctic Circle the
Russians have also announced they sit in
an underwater submarine underwater
submarines where do submarines go I mean
if yes you know to the underneath the
polar cap to go to the North Pole to put
a plaque they're saying this is our so
they're claiming this territory there's
a lot out there and that's that's a part
of it has to do with the tax regime a
part of it has to do to bring in foreign
companies the bigger question and the
one that fascinates me is why companies
like she'll like every major company
ConocoPhillips got smart and said we'll
hold our investment to 20% because when
you get above that then you you begin to
make Putin nervous and BP made a mistake
a 50/50 adventure of investment in a
joint venture in shell has been shell
made some mistakes too they went in to
develop Sakhalin which is an island off
the Pacific which is given a very
difficult working conditions they went
and they say well we will we will have a
arrangement whereby we will be able to
get all our investment back before you
the government get any money and we
think it will be ten billion dollars
because it's going to be very difficult
it turns out they say now it's 20
billion dollars the Russians are what
you know that means we won't ever see
our money and you're going to be taking
our resources you're going to be making
it and we won't
and so they'd then basically pushed
shell out is that they brought in a new
partner Gazprom and so in these
circumstances you have to be sensitive
to the fact that the Russians treat this
as their holy of holies and if you look
like you're doing something at their
expense you're going to a court trouble
but I asked these oil companies
executives why are you doing this you
know you're going to get caught in this
whipsaw sooner or later and I say well
look where are we going to go okay it's
been suggested we go to Peru and there's
a Shining Path if we have to deal with
the Shining Path we'd rather deal with
the KGB and gospel but those are our
alternatives and so if God did not put
oil in nice places and we have to deal
on that basis and so they know it and I
think the Russians feel they can do it
and also in terms of gas that what I
argue in the book is that they also can
control what's going on in Central Asia
and Putin has handled that very well
he really is the man from Goss probe if
somebody else Dick Cheney goes to
Kazakhstan and tells tries to tell the
people because excited that they should
support the building of a bypass gas
pipeline under the Caspian Sea to avoid
a Russia Putin flies that in the next
able to do that and you know that's
applied a pie in the sky you're going to
put money in that has never come to
reality we're here we're real stick with
us and basically sabotaged alexei miller
the CEO of gospel is said again in
recent interview just this last week
part of the his advice is we welcome the
investment you just better invest with
the state company and you better do it
at a percentage that is acceptable and
that's probably a moving target next
question please
wait for the microphone line let me just
say why the microphone is going there
what is happening as more and more
Western firms are going there as service
companies when we went out to Siberia
what we found was that a slumbers a the
French American company was there in
Halliburton
dick cheney's old company there's
they're the ones who are actually doing
the drilling and they're you take your
commission you know you don't develop an
equity and the Russians are happy with
that but the rest you're absolutely
right they don't they get nervous if you
develop a declination that way they can
get the technology but not give up any
equity of their national interest
nationalistic interest in preserving the
wealth that comes from their natural
resources yeah John's from law a marshal
thanks for a great talk could you
reflect a little bit on the triangle of
Russia China and the US and are you and
Merrill didn't have something to say on
that soon yeah I said I should say my
wife is a China specialist that's a
fascinating triangle to the Russians are
very nervous because as you know we just
heard his wayne indicated there is more
and more movement to talk develop energy
in East Siberia which is of course just
in Maritime Provinces and that's where
there are lots of Chinese more than that
the Russians from that part of the area
of a lot of a stock are moving to the
west on top of that if that weren't
enough the biggest problem that Putin
probably has to deal with orbit again of
the new president is the fact that the
Russian population is shrinking it's
falling 700,000 people a year it you
know that's not unique it's happening in
Europe too many countries as well but it
means that when there are say six to
eight million Russians in Siberia and
the Maritime Provinces on the Pacific
and there are 3040 million Chinese eager
to across the border that makes them
nervous then you go there we've traveled
a lot there and what you find is
construction crews are more and more
Chinese you go into the markets you find
the Chinese are the ones selling the
goods from across the border this causes
a lot of local racism anger xenophobia
indeed that their laws now pushing out
the
a foreigners not just the Chinese but
the Central Asians as well from some of
their markets but it's a problem and it
creates a tension at the same time the
two of them Russia and China
linked up together and joining the
Shanghai Cooperation agreement which
also brings into Central Asia against
the United States and this I think is a
shortcoming of our foreign policy that
we've done things that have brought them
together in a way that normally they
wouldn't be together because naturally
if left on their own there there would
be problems the the Chinese would help
the Russians in the sense that they came
in and bought lots of military equipment
but just provoked a big debate in in
Russia it was as if you know Lenin was
supposed to say that we don't know if he
did that the capitalist will sell us the
rope that will hang them and so the what
the Russians were saying we're selling
the military equipment too may come back
to haunt us the tiny thing that we're
going to use against Taiwan but but
don't you know they've come together
this way so there is a lot of natural
rivalry that's there that could indeed
cause lots of problems in the context of
political interaction and engagement and
even rivalry this makes sense their
concern Russians have to be concerned
about this this goes back a thousand
years of concern about what's coming out
of the east on the other hand from a
purely commercial point of view if you
if you look at it is Russia Inc orgoth
Pro mink or Russ net you said this week
in another interview with Russians media
that is also India I mean from a
commercial standpoint China and India
the two other enormous league growing
economies so you've got a commercial
interest and a political interest in it
the question is how do those tie
together well it looks in the case of
India at this point although India's
become much closer to us recently but
before
Russia and India were pretty close again
but partly as a play against China now
in this this is Guinea India's part of
this thing but there there is another
aspect which is drawing both the
Russians and the Chinese together and
that's the Islamic thing because the
Chinese have a problem in cynjohn which
is in northwest China they have been the
violence terrorism there because there's
a very strong Islamic Chinese group the
weekers that are there and they want
independence and we were there two years
ago in in a room key which is the one of
the one place where the Chinese actually
produce some petroleum and there was
they were about to mark the celebration
of the incorporation of cynjohn into
china which the leaguers were not happy
about and there were soldiers Chinese
soldiers parading in the markets in the
streets with open bayonets just because
they were worried about this thing that
so the Russians are concerned about this
and Kazakhstan they're worried about
this whose Becca said they're worried
about and that was also partly the thing
that the Shanghai Cooperation agreement
was to draw them together and the
stomachs that we did that so they to the
extent we get back in there we say no
this is something we're we have a mutual
interest in there so there are is where
they indeed have mutual concerns but but
underlying it there there is potential
historic as you say rivalry that that on
occasion has led to violence the
Russians the Soviets of the Chinese were
shooting at each other in 1962 in one in
the back what neck from thank you very
much oh is the price of natural gas
still subsidized in Russia I mean does
it sell below you might say the market
price in Western Europe yeah and what
what is the outlook that natural gas
prices inside of Russia
well we'll go up this has provoked a big
debate in in Russia because what you
know one of the things that should
happen this is our natural gas it's
rubbing Russia's natural gas there
should be some benefit to the population
are you going to charge world prices and
push us out of the market so for a long
time the price of petroleum as well but
especially natural gas was heavily
subsidized or at least it did not meet
what the world market price was for
example they were selling natural gas to
Germany and a hundred and fifty dollars
a thousand cubic meters in inside Russia
it was about forty fifty dollars and
also they were selling it at the same
price to some of the former republics a
Ukraine in particular and that later set
off a big battle with Ukraine because
the Russian said you're no longer part
of us you should be paying world prices
too and that's when they began to cut
back the flow of gas to Ukraine which in
turn cut it off to Russia you know if
the big problem is if while you want to
subsidize your local public and if you
raise the price you know you're going to
have political protests and and you're
going to get all kinds of difficulty
that way so you don't want to do that at
the same time unless you do price it at
the world price and here's the
economists coming in you're going to get
wasteful use of it you know even free
love after well you begin to waste those
those resources you know and so you want
to have a proper price for that so this
was an argument and Putin ultimately
agreed the Duma ultimately agreed they
would gradually begin to raise the price
to the to the world market as depending
on what kind of price a gospel was
getting it generally so this is already
beginning to happen of course
the trouble is world energy prices keep
going up so you say well we'll bring it
up to the level of 2006 but we're we're
pretty far beyond that but the goal is
within the next year or two to make it
comparable to indeed make sure that it's
used efficiently and if nothing else to
make sure there's
thing to to export so it's a problem
they recognize and it's it's one that
they seem to be coping with and so far
there haven't been these protests that
if they did it all at once probably
would happen but the trouble is it's
chasing a moving target your husband is
also said in a negative that he wants to
develop industry well if you're going to
develop indigenous industry you must
have energy to supply those factories I
think I promise you please use a mic
thank you and we are talking about much
wealth which would imply ownership what
is the status of the legal system in
terms of private property rights have
there been any reforms yeah boy oh boy
oh boy my my previous book was called
the pirate ization of russia which
really looked at this kind of thing and
and this is in some ways an extension of
that you can own private property and
your so you know the companies had been
private they took the Ministry of the
petroleum industry and broke it up and
into all these different companies
although Rosneft the state still owned
the majority of shares of rough Rosneft
gas palm at one point state ownership
fell to 38 percent Putin saw this could
be a problem that it could be taken over
by foreigners and so he's pushed it back
up so the state now owns 51% of Gazprom
so but you can own private shares in it
the trouble is if you cross the state I
mean if you counter what what whatever
Putin wants Putin gets if you don't do
that then you run the risk of having
visits from the whole variety of things
the internal tax people you know we had
something like this in the United States
under Nixon you've got visits from the
IRS if if you were doing something that
the government and that was one of the
reasons why this led to the engagement
of Russians call it the creative use of
administrative resources that's right at
the one
yes well well it says it's the same it's
the same notion of the Communists but
here here the right you know it's not
just limited to the tax people the tax
people went out after Khodorkovsky and
Yukos but now what is happening is that
BP and she'll got visits from the
pollution people now they violated
pollution they were polluting although
if you've ever been in a Russian oil
field before this new era the Russian
companies Soviet companies were
notorious for the way they wasted
resources because it was underpriced it
was just just a you know terrible
violation of of nature but you know one
way or another if they want you they're
going to get you and and you go into
this that's why you know should we go to
the Shining Path you just you come in
and you're going to take your knocks for
me it's humiliating and I've just
written something more just about this
where the president of the Shell Oil
operating in Sakhalin says ok it's not
ten billion dollars our expenses are
it's it's twenty million dollars and
then he is told you violated the
environmental rules and unless you would
agree to a I'm gonna make you a
proposition you can't refuse like you
know out of the Godfather unless you
agree to that we're going to take over
the whole company so they agree to let
gospel come in at a fraction of a gospel
bought it for about six seven billion
dollars already shell is put in ten
billion and the chairman of Shell Oil's
says we're happy you know hit me again
we're happy for this kind of thing but
you play out it's their baseball it's
their baseball bat it's their baseball
field
it's the baseball glove and you want to
operate you've got you've got to simply
allow for they can still confiscate it
and this is what I've got a cough ski
every one of the oligarchs knows that
this could happen
I'll take something from the other side
well you had your hand up a long time
but on time
go ahead and then we'll come back dr.
gold meter in the 90s gas problem most
of the Russian manufacturing were still
based upon an allocation type of system
and a lot of their entrance into the
Western world was using variable pricing
and it seemed that fixed pricing
investment just wasn't part of their
vocabulary has that changed from what
you're seeing that they understand the
need for long term investments and fixed
price yes they have indeed signed these
long term contracts but like other
energy companies if prices go up as much
as they have there are ways of
convincing you that maybe we should make
an adjustment in what is happening
there's a fire in the pipeline something
goes wrong so while they indeed are
happy to sign these long-term contracts
they usually now smart enough to know
that there are other things that they
should allow for some kind of adjustment
mechanism there and you know in fairness
to them this is this is the world price
why should you be locked in there
forever so so they're not they're not
taking a beating we're gospel is taking
a beating and somebody mentioned it here
earlier in the discussion is that
because it's a national champion that
means that the state works on your
behalf externally and you carry the flag
but it also means that you have
commitments internally and by that it
means the puja today we're going to have
de limpets the Winter Olympics in Sochi
we've got to have somebody finance the
building of this I think that would be a
good project for you to undertake no
commercial relevance for taking the
resources that are being generated
elsewhere using them in a whole series
of infrastructure projects that should
be rightfully the domain of the state
not of a private company so you know
that's where God's problem has its
problems but in terms of contracts as
far as I know they're they're still
doing okay and they're getting they're
managing to get
long-term prices that are adjustable one
way or another so that they they don't
suffer this way if I might take a Prague
was really the other side of not taking
a prerogative since I'm only
president-elect we Peter had his hand up
we better left they still current
president southern senator ask a
question if you like if you have a
country that has thirty four million
Muslims and a population something less
than 130 million of birthrates and free
fall you have a mortality rate which is
dropping almost a Soviet standards and
you've got problems like you've
indicated with the Chinese is it not
possible that one day the the Russian
authorities might look at the United
States as a possibly a very viable ally
because you know they're going to be
they're going to be outflanked they you
can't have a great nation unless you
have people and they don't have and will
not have the people well you know this I
mentioned earlier that that Putin the
Russians problem the biggest problem
right now love so many their list is
pretty long but one of the one near the
top is the fact that it's shrink 700,000
people a year and and if you look at a
population tree one of the diagrams I
pass out in you know other lectures is
the population tree which is normally a
kind of a pyramid or a triangle where
what you do is you take people by age
after one years of age some people die
so that shrinks until you get up to the
60s and you know life expectancy now
from for Russian men is about 58 59 so
if we were doing this right now in
Moscow there would be very few of us in
the room I mean you know that
so women it's a women it's a little
little longer so and and and worst of
all when when Yeltsin took over people
just stopped having children so as you
as you mentioned and so the population
tree looks something like this you know
just it it looks like a knot I know what
it looks like but it comes up and then
it goes up like this
and unless Putin can come up with some
way of having women give birth to 12
years olds you know you're never going
to fill this this year so so the number
of people who are entering the workforce
now because that's that's this this area
here is very low that also means the
army it also means that you're not going
to have people for for the military and
so this the population thing is real
well in ancient well that's that's why
one of the reasons why life expectancy
is so so short 58 59 alcoholism smoking
is dropped a little bit but traffic
action one of the our sessions with
Putin's he was asked about this and he
said well if you live to 65 year okay
but you've got to be able to survive
those traffic death the alcohol is and
then once you're at 65 your life
expectancy would be like it is in other
countries but you we can't get people up
there and so Putin recognizing this has
reintroduced the programs that used to
be prominent in the Soviet era where you
give big bonuses to women with lots of
children marriage is also a problem I
mean you know somewhat like the United
States now that fewer people born more
and more people are having children out
of wedlock witches which is not a good
way to bring up children and so they're
they're worried about this and they so
it he's got his hands full this way and
it does indeed suggest that of putin's
aspirations i think he has aspirations
to be a super military power the trouble
is the military right now is not in a
position to do it and they're draftees
aren't going to be there and there are
all ways of getting out of the drafts or
all kinds of other things they torture
the draftees and ways of death suicide
rate among draftees
you know one of the highest rates of the
world because they just can't take the
hazing it's just everything that could
go wrong they do so that population
thing is clearly something that is a
nightmare that Putin has to deal with
and a successor in Sibylla Mike here for
Peter one of the solutions I heard to
Russia's declining population is this
since China has a surplus of men and
Russia has a surplus of women that
you're going to find the average cup
will be an old Russian woman with a
younger Chinese husband and I read that
summer but I can't give you the source
professor Goldman back to the
conversation that we had briefly during
the reception about Iran referring to
the Islamic question I'm really quite
worried about Russia having provided a
run with technology for nuclear power it
has dual use and not having made
agreements to get back to spend fuel up
front which I don't think they didn't
you can correct me if I'm wrong and it's
a little bit late to lock the barn right
now couldn't they be doing more to
restrain Iran from developing nuclear
weapons because it will activate
Russia's Muslims don't they understand
that the actually it's an interesting
question the the Russians are aware of
this Pope is aware of this in whatever
you want to say about Putin he's not a
dummy and he's very conscious of this
thing in fact the last visit we had to
this this group that goes over there and
we meet with with you really was looking
at a Russian the Islamic question and
when they took us to Kazan which is the
head of the capital of the Tatar
Republic in inside Russia and we spent a
lot of time going to the mosque a lot of
time going to the Russian Orthodox
Church hearing both the local Iman and
the local patriarch there talk about how
well they're getting along with each
other so this is something they really
are worried about and they're very sense
- there was a time when to his credit
Putin said okay we're going to stop just
stop the construction of that of that
reactor because we were they Russians
did not have the guarantee they were
looking for I've heard from American
diplomats in Moscow that they are
satisfied with the sharing of
intelligence that the Russians have
provided with the United States you know
it's not so much an Iran that the
Russians worry about although they if
you if there's a problem they're much
closer to around and that we are in this
country it's Afghanistan and you know
the Russians have had their experience
in Afghanistan it's their Vietnam or if
you want their Iraq if you will and it's
it they were just one of the reasons for
this whole collapse was that they just
ran aground in Afghanistan so there they
appreciate that
and again one of the I think the merits
of this Bush Putin relationship is that
that has served as one of the areas
where they do cooperate so in answer to
your question yes there's much more I
would like Russia to do but again unlike
what it was in the Soviet era where you
know in the case of Iraq for example
even under under Gorbachev the Russians
purposely did everything they could to
expand not just the civilian use of
nuclear energy but military use of
energy as a way of provoking us as a way
of harassing us and that that's not
happening now there's not that kind of
rivalry a provocation that existed
earlier a lot more could be done and I
would hope that it would be but it's not
as bad as it could be
separately are federally the mic might
be I think Thank You professor Goldman
you've alluded to the poor state of
manufacturing but could you say
something more about the general state
of the economy and how well it's
functioning your banking system credit
systems smaller shops other forms of
business because you sort of get the
feeling that there is this huge amount
of wealth floating around but at the
same time the rest of the economy is a
real question mark yeah we talked a
little bit about this earlier overall
you know and all this money flowing in
covers a lot of problems it masks a lot
of problems and all that oil revenue but
you know there's as I said before all
that oil revenue means these mentors as
Wayne said you had the Dutch disease so
manufacturing suffers but the bigger
problem is corruption the bigger problem
is that there's no tradition of
Independence from the government so for
me the biggest index or marker of
Russians the state of the health of
Russian economy is what is the role of
small business can you start small
business what is the role of innovation
and there it's it's very dismal the
share of small business and the GDP is
in Russia is of ten to fifteen percent
whereas in this country it's 50 percent
or more in Europe it's it's it's about
that high I mean as somebody whose son
is there was an entrepreneur who's
indeed sold his business to a company
here and in Atlanta I'm very much a
proponent of small business and watching
innovation and Russia innovation you
start up the minute that you I did some
interviewing along these lines with
people set up their own business the
minute that you put an ad in the paper
that you're doing well or that you're
looking for partners you get a visit
from the Mafia and today it's not the
Mafia so much as the government and you
fingers where the mafia begins and the
government ends because in very it's
much the same kind of thing so this is
just terribly destructive instead of
encouraging this kind of thing it's just
you you you keep knock it right down and
and and you you heard it now you know
that understands this I think and tries
to do something but but so far not been
very successful the new President Dmitry
Medvedev who comes from Goss problem
which is not a small company I think
understands this a little bit he was
trained as a lawyer he practice law he
believes in the rule of the law and in
fact one of the things he said in in
describing what was going on with the
Western oil companies and the oligarchs
he said we had the Neel ISM of the law
you know just that rule of laws just
gone and so one of the things he said
early on he's only been the president
for a few weeks he said one of the
things I want to do is to set up a
commission on corruption and I'll be the
chair it and for me this was a signal
this was a gig at Putin why is there
need for such a commission because
things have deteriorated things have
gotten worse on your watch and you
former lieutenant colonel in the KGB
should have been able to cope with this
and instead it's gotten worse and and on
the list you know the internet there are
international groups that list
corruption Russia has fallen so it's
gotten worse and this is so what the
attentive is saying I'm going to try to
clean it up because you Putin didn't do
it that may be one way of kind of
establishing is his independence from
Putin instead of being this protege but
in answer to your question the rest of
the economy is not in good shape
agriculture strangely enough is picking
up a little bit I mean Wayne used to
sell them chickens and other things that
and now now what is happening the
Russians have kind of given up being
self-sufficient and and producing their
own feedstock so what they're doing is
they're buying you know more meat from
the West they're just trying to not try
to grow feed grains because it's too far
north to do that even when there was not
the core
even when you didn't have the collective
farm system so there they're beginning
to export actually some weakness which
that which they didn't do before but
small business is a problem you know if
you have a chance to go to Russia we'll
see a lot of these Street merchants in
kiosks and one of the things I always do
is ask them how much you have to pay the
police to be here and you can get a rate
and the rate goes up each year of course
because of inflation about it it's a
they won't tell you at first but because
they don't know what what you're doing
but you can usually find out and it is
it is not not healthy it's not just not
a healthy system there is a growing
sentiment in Russia although as you know
in the Senate and some of the other
government agencies to prevent imports
of food as if it's what we call we have
to raise it in these that means you
raise in martial arts Peter's going to
die with chicken diplomacy is really
active right right now this week there
are many many meetings going on because
some parts of the Russian business
community and government are trying to
once again raise a certain kind of not
our protection
protective issues there because
ultimately they would like to be
self-sufficient in agriculture we have
to say historically we know and it was
in your book from 1995 to the beginning
of the first world war I mean this is
the grain basket the basket of Europe
they had major exports and some people
say in the in the in the United Nations
and other places that actually Russia
could be a potential source for the
world food supply situation so
particularly in this today when to
prices are going when the food prices
the oil prices are so high yeah
we've got about a few minutes at 6 or 7
minutes or something dr. Floyd dr.
Goldman thank you for coming to southern
centers to like to have you as in the
words of our president I look into your
eyes and see your soul I want to know
what you when you look into the crystal
ball what do you see in 10 or 20 years
in Russia what how does it how is it
playing with the United States how is it
playing with its neighbors as a cut-off
gas to Eastern Europe what's the future
hold well I should tell you who somebody
asks before about my wife or China and
one of the things we do we give this
show a dance performance where we look
at where do we see China 10 years from
now where do we see Russia where do we
see the United States and if you I make
a diagram and if you plot the economists
coming out at me if you plot
capabilities with with aspirations the
best way to say Japan has aspirations
that are rather limited at this point
but it's a lot of capabilities China
early on 10 years ago 20 years ago had a
lot of aspirations but didn't have much
the weight capabilities but if you
project it where it is today where it's
where it's been where it's going where
it's going to be you got to say watch
out because it's going up in that in
that direction and Russia collapsed 10
years ago it was at the bottom as its
abilities that didn't have the
capabilities at all now Putin does come
back we want to be a great superpower
again superpower certainly in terms of
energy maybe down the road but military
as well but it sooner or later with this
wealth unless they can not solve the
population problem they're going to
address it so but where are we in the
United States that's the thing that
scares me most of all because we've been
bankrupting ourselves if you look at
what are the ways I look at this is one
of our traits our trade deficit
the Russians are having a trade surplus
each year of 120 billion dollars I don't
mean to be a mercantilist but you know
with a trade deficit of about 700
two billion dollars a year oil imports
about 400 billion dollars here where
we're dependent on other countries our
deficit you know and you look to see
where the country is going it it's scary
it is it is scary but lucky you maybe
this is a something that I should tell
you about this business I looked into
his eyes and got a sense of his soul
because I mentioned before this odd
couple the oddest couple I've ever seen
in my life the two of them I'm not
seeing them together physically but I've
watched them on television their body
language really strange and I said that
Putin four times now I've heard him
bring up a bush in the most
complimentary way and so where did it
come from well if you go back to the
year 2000 of the election in the United
States
borsch and Condoleezza Rice said you
know to discredit Gore who headed a
Joint Commission with turtle mere did
the guy here who was had his own
problems they said well we're not going
to have any more but some of meetings
bilateral meetings that we gave too much
away we they didn't really pressure
journal mierda in the way they should so
when we take over we won't have that and
they continued that after the election
in you know 2001 and it continued until
there was remember there was a crash
between an American plane and a Chinese
plane in April 2001
I think off on an island and then
suddenly the United States was being
criticized by both Russia and China and
at that point the administration changed
their stories okay we'll go back to this
meeting so there was a meeting in
Slovenia summit between the two of them
and in preparation for this meeting
Condoleezza Rice gave President Bush
this little book to read which is called
first-person it's in English it's
translated from russian and it's a
series of interviews with with a Putin
with his family with his work associates
with people who knew him because it was
Putin all of a sudden
what was he all about and in it Putin's
mother describes how he/she and her her
Putin's grandmother had Putin secretly
baptized you didn't want to do that
because Putin's father and grandfather
had worked for the KGB that's not the
way to win points we secretly baptize
the 1993 in masovia still in the Soviet
era they I'm sorry it still the Russian
I put this is just a official he and his
wife go to Israel and they and on the
occasion they're going Bouton's mother
gives him a cross and says when you get
to Jerusalem have this cross blessed by
the Russian Orthodox priest of the
Russian Orthodox Church has a very
strong presence in Jerusalem he did he
comes back called 1996-1997 i'm not sure
of the exact year he builds a adachi
summer home with with a sauna the saunas
faulty it catches fire Putin is in it
naked the whole thing burns down he's
lost the cross among everything else a
fireman comes by so mr. Putin I think
this cross is yours was saved at the
fart Bush reads that he goes to this
meeting in Slovenia and he says tell me
about the cross and for born-again
Christian this was very important and
that was the basis where I looked into
his he comes out of that meeting and he
says I looked into his eyes and I got a
sense of the soul and I read that in his
what the hell is that all about
you know I look into his eyes he's a KGB
agent my father was a head of the CIA
okay
or I looked into his eyes he's got
teenage daughters I've got teenage
daughters you know I understand his
problem now I have to tell you I told
that story in a lecture I gave in
Jacksonville Florida of all places to a
Wellesley group and a big man comes up
to me afterwards he says about that
story you told I said today about Bush
and Putin if I'm Bush's uncle and I said
oh god did I get it wrong he says well
only in part that wasn't in the middle
of the meeting it was at the beginning
of the meeting and and Bush wouldn't lay
off till Putin answered and Putin
you couldn't understand what the hell is
has got to do with with anything but but
it turns out it's a true story and it
helps to explain this bond between the
two of them and then of course after
9/11 you know that Putin was the first
one to get a hold of bush to offer help
to commiserate and that's because
there's a hotline nobody else could get
through lines busy except for the
hotline so this was a remnant of this
and so that also helped to do this local
company here many years and and when it
got to the of the end he would stand up
and he'd look at the audience regardless
of whether it was his audience or
somebody else's audience and say boys
and girls tomorrow morning we have class
the meeting is adjourned thank you very
much that's a realistic I'm laying thank
you for your service yes thank you for
meeting is adjourned
very good
yeah yes then have a chance to ask
Sheriff
Marshall Goldman is a senior scholar at
the Davis center for Russian studies at
Harvard University and an economics
professor emeritus at Wellesley College
mr. Goldman's writing has appeared in
several publications including the
Washington Post The Atlantic Monthly and
foreign affairs for more information
visit the publishers website at oh you
pee comm backslash us treat a Parsi this